je m'appelle nicolas signer
six ans et je suis expert en économie
circulaire et en management public
alors j'ai toujours détesté les
injustices tout petit déjà elle me
révolte et je crois qu'en grandissant
ça n'a pas vraiment changé j'ai souhaité
améliorer la vie des gens
bonifier leur bonheur leur apprentissage
de la vie
j'ai envisagé de devenir médecin de
devenir humanitaire et je suis devenu
hydrogéologue avec un objectif
travailler au renforcement du bien
commun alors après quelques années
d'exercice
j'ai décidé de prendre le pouvoir le
pouvoir de changer profondément la
société
le chant le pouvoir de la transformer et
ça vous faire bizarre mais je suis
devenu haut fonctionnaire mon métier
concevoir des politiques publiques et
les mettre en oeuvre
alors depuis dix ans je suis directeur
général d'une collectivité territoriale
qui assure la collecte la valorisation
le recyclage le tri des déchets de plus
de deux cent mille habitants
c'est notre quotidien notre quotidien
c'est transporter le poids de l'erdre de
l'airbus a380 tous les jours mais ce
quotidien ce n'est pas tout c'est aussi
une politique publique notre volonté de
changer considérablement le regard votre
regard sur les déchets la gestion des
déchets est un vrai projet politique
ces connexions avec la santé
l'alimentation la biodiversité
même la culture ce soir sont très fortes
la gestion des déchets participent au
réchauffement climatique vous le savez
et par conséquent et elle a croisé deux
causes environnementales et sociales
alors au delà des impacts
environnementaux que l'on re découvre
très souvent dans les médias en ce
moment c'est les plastique dans les
océans
la gestion des déchets et des ressources
l'extraction de ressources
la conception des produits l'utilisation
et l'élimination injuste sur des déchets
des ressources renforce considérablement
les inégalités dans le monde
pourquoi parce que les plus démunis sont
les premières victimes des conflits
géostratégique d'accès aux ressources
n'est pas sans savoir que plus de 2
milliards d'individus n'ont toujours pas
accès à l'eau potable que nos déchets
des déchets aujourd'hui nos déchets sont
priés sont valorisés par les plus
démunis souvent dans des conditions
insupportables
enfin les plus démunis n'ont que
rarement la possibilité de s'adapter de
changer leur existence de d'être
résilient ils n'ont d'ailleurs jamais le
pouvoir pour cela
alors vous comprenez que la gestion des
déchets des ressources et un sujet
crucial très politique
et personnellement ça vous ment tout cas
moi il me passionne et me fascine à quoi
ça vous fait penser cette tour eiffel
à paris cette tour eiffel elle effective
en appareils des raisons c'est bien ça
c'est tour eiffel c'est la production de
déchets des français toutes les dix
minutes
et pour produire fabriquer les objets
qui viennent d'être jeté en dix minutes
il a fallu extraire dans le monde entier
30 tour eiffel de ressources minières
est utilisé l'équivalent 30 tour eiffel
d'eau potable
cette tour eiffel de déchets produits
tous les dix minutes c'est notre air
notre réalité une réalité que nous
voulons pas voir et pourtant elle est
bien là alors cette situation elle ne
peut plus durer
on va attendre que le progrès ou la
science sans charge
nous vivons à crédit ou s'il ya des
économistes dans la salle sur nos fonds
propres alors avec en 2014 avec mes
collègues mes collaborateurs nous avons
souhaité vraiment changer les choses
nous avons souhaité transformer modifier
la pratique des usagers alors pas encore
une fois en communiquant sensibilisant
en attendant un hypothétique changement
de comportement mais bien en innovant
radicalement pour fabriquer la réalité
de demain
alors pourquoi innover parce que le
monde des déchets n'a pas évolué depuis
40 ans que les mêmes recettes utilisées
encore aujourd'hui produire elles mêmes
résultats et ça c'est très décevant
nous nous sommes fait piéger par les
gestionnaires de déchets et j'en fais
partie
c'est comment vous à piéger en vous
disant donnez-nous vos déchets on s'en
occupe et deuxièmement parce que innover
parce que le monde puyol aujourd'hui
d'initiative on l'a vu tout à l'heure
locale
très rapide porté par des entrepreneurs
des start up des associations et ce
monde il bouillonne il va plus vite que
les institutions que
présente et en tant que responsable
d'institution je me devais d'innover
pour rattraper ce monde qui va plus vite
que moi
et enfin parce que innover vous le savez
c'est très efficace et pragmatique c'est
donner de l'espoir
nous souhaitions trouver des solutions
simples et efficaces pour changer le
regard des usagers sur leurs déchets
pour leur permettre de moins produire de
déchets de plus recyclé nous souhaitions
et vous allez vous dire il est
complètement dingue que le sujet des
déchets qui est un sujet qui est une
contrainte aujourd'hui pour nous tous
deviennent un sujet sexy oui je me dis
sexy alors avec une équipe atypique
pluridisciplinaire sociologue designer
expert en animation en communication
ingénieurs nous avons gré le premier
supermarché inverser une véritable
innovation de rupture dans le domaine
alors le contexte nous avions deux
millions d'euros à investir pour
reconstruire une déchetterie je sais pas
si vous avez êtes déjà allé dans une
déchetterie mais cet équipement conçu
dans les années 80 pour traiter le
problème des années 80 c'était
impossible pour nous de reproduire le
même exercice
alors nous avons créé un supermarché
inversée alors imaginez un supermarché
dans lequel vos déchets deviennent des
ressources c'est vous même qui placer
vos déchets devenus objets et matériaux
dans des rayons et dans lequel
gratuitement vous acceptez vous accédez
et vous pouvez récupérer autant d'objets
et de matériaux que vous le souhaitez ce
supermarché inversée nous l'avons créé
sur une petite commune s'appelle vercken
vingtaine de kilomètres de bordeaux
ils permettent de permet de redonner une
seconde vie aux déchets de façon ludique
et efficace
alors comment ça marche on l'a dit
on rentre dans un supermarché inverser
les déchets deviennent des ressources on
les place dans des rayons et pompeux
gratuitement récupérer des objets ou des
matériaux dès l'entrée comme dans la
dans un supermarché on est tout de suite
happé par trois totems qui vont vous
aider à faire le bon geste le bon choix
apportez vous un objet ou un os des
matériaux est il en état ou à recycler
est ce un petit ou un gros volume puis
vous rentrez dans un magasin de
bricolage à ces gros 5000 mètres carrés
et vous avez baigné dans le monde de la
consommation avec ses codes ses rayons
c'est qu'a dit vous allez ensuite
pouvoir accéder à trois grandes zones
qui vont accueillir la maison des objets
le préau des matériaux et puis une zone
un peu plus classique de dépôt comme
dans une déchetterie classique dans la
maison des objets vous allez pouvoir
apporter des déchets devenu ressources
les placer dans des rayons cuisine
buanderie
il fit des technologies en france
bricolage jardinage sport dans cet
espace vous allez pousser le trio
maximum vous allez pouvoir recycler de
façon innovante les gours de compote
pour enfants des capsules de café
les cd les cartes de fidélité ensuite
vous allez pouvoir vous diriger vers le
préau des matériaux alors comme son nom
l'indiqué le préau des matériaux
imaginer c'est le bonheur des bricoleurs
j'en suis pas un banc tout cas je sais
que ces jeux c'est le bonheur des
bricoleurs de la même façon vous allez
pouvoir accéder à certains nombre de
rayons et récupérer des parpaings de la
peinture un morceau de bois une fenêtre
un câble électrique une gouttière vous
allez aussi dans cet espace pouvoir
naviguer en tout cas récupérer dans un
espace ameublement des chaises des
tables d
et enfin pour terminer dans comme dans
une déchetterie un petit peu plus
classique vous allez pouvoir déposer vos
végétaux vos déchets de chantier mais
encore une fois nous avons poussé le
concept jusqu'au bout dans cet espace
vous allez récupérer du bois pour
chevauchent au fait du compost des
éviers d un bac à douche ou d'autres
éléments issus de la maçonnerie
tout au long de votre expérience votre
votre parcours usagers dans l'équipement
vous allez accompagner l'idée 106 visés
comme dans la grande distribution
parent personnes accueille un chef de
rayon par un logisticien
manutentionnaire tous formés par la
grande distribution
vous l'aurez compris ni une déchetterie
nine recyclerie le supermarché inversée
utilisant les codes de la consommation
bouleverse les repères que l'on a depuis
des dizaines d'années lorsque vous allez
dans une déchetterie ou dans une
recyclerie votre décision vous la fête à
la maison avant de prendre votre voiture
et elle est souvent irrévocable
c'est une décision de jeter de trier de
données mais c'est une décision qui
ferme le supermarché inversée vous
redonne la possibilité de décider
puisque c'est au moment où vous allez
faire votre geste que vous aurez toutes
les possibilités
conçu en 2015 et construit en 2016
le supermarché inversée a ouvert ses
portes le 10 avril 2010 est alors
imaginez un ouverture vis à vis un ca
supermarché après un an de
fonctionnement
les résultats sont bien au delà des
objectifs que nous nous étions fixés
d'abord quantitativement imaginer 30% de
déchets évités 1500 tonnes d'objets de
matériaux échangés entre les habitants
et c'est dix mille habitants petites
surfaces moins 65 % de déchets destinés
à la décharge
et enfin pour les objets les matériaux
qui resteraient sur resterait sur les
sites plus de 85 % partent vers des
filières de recyclage local pour être
valorisés mais je dirais que c'est pas
le plus important ce qui est le plus
important c'est l'aspect qualitatif
notre objectif c'était de changer le
regard des usagers sur leurs déchets
alors
kit j'allais dans une déchetterie la
salle alors beaucoup en fait comment
vous quand vous êtes dans votre voiture
c'est quoi votre ressenti vous êtes oui
du gâchis alors je sentais bien vous
êtes on se débarrasse way dans une
déchetterie classique
en général on est impatient on est
pressé on a envie de jeter on veut bien
trier mais bon faut que ce soit facile
statistiquement on veut rester entre
sept et huit minutes sur le supermarché
inversée on y reste 20 30 minutes dans
un environnement agréable beau en effet
les belles rencontres
on y est on y échange des pratiques on y
échange tout un tas d'objets bref c'est
quand même plus cool quoi toute la
société défilent à la différence d'une
déchetterie des jeunes des enfants des
familles des couples des personnes plus
âgées
après un an de fonctionnement
le supermarché inversée va encore plus
loin puisque localement nous avons
travaillé avec les startups
d'entrepreneurs des associations pour
mettre en place localement un éco
système permettant de créer de
l'activité économique et un certain
nombre de nouvelles filières président
aux ventes qui devrait on l'espère
irrigué bien au delà de la gironde
permettent
vous le voyez sur cette île hyde de
réparer fabriquer des vélo vintage des
meubles de recycler des capsules on a
parlé des capsules des cafés recycler la
peinture et cet écosystème elle a permis
de créer des emplois et ses emplois ils
sont non délocalisables
ça c'est important pour nous c'est
important quand on sait que 10 me
tonnes de déchets incinérés envoyé dans
une décharge créer un emploi
dix mille tonnes de déchets recyclés
créer dix emplois
dix mille tonnes de déchets réemployer
réparer relooké à votre avis à cri
combien d'emplois sans alors bon c'est
vrai que c'est un peu facile mais en
fait dans 6 50 et c'est déjà beaucoup
c'est déjà beaucoup si 50 emplois le
potentiel est énorme
et en plus si des emplois non
délocalisables la version v2 est la
version v3 des 300 pleine préparation
alors la version v2 sera ouvert aux
artisans vous imaginez que le préau des
matériaux quelque chose de plus
consistant
il permettra également d'apporter des
services supplémentaires aux habitants
et notamment des services de réparation
par action de d'électroménager
réparation meubles par exemple la
version des trois sera encore plus
ambitieux prendra évidemment le retour
d'expérience de l'a1 de la 2 la 3 sera
installé en plein centre de la ville de
libourne sur 11000 mètres carrés et elle
accueillera également une galerie
marchande dédié spécifiquement aux
objets issus du réemploi
elle accueillera également une
conciergerie est certainement un
incubateur 0 ace pour tous les
entrepreneurs les associations les
acteurs qui veulent se lancer dans cette
démarche la prise de risque
la logique et ses erreurs le droit à
l'expérimentation nous a permis de créer
le premier supermarché inverser un
équipement visités par le monde entier
alors je vous avouerai qu'il ya pas
encore de croître j'espère qu'ils
viendront liberge
mais on a été visité par des brésiliens
des américains italiens belges
ben oui belge quand même espagnol
japonais
une vingtaine de pays africains une
centaine d'entreprises et collectivités
françaises même le prix goldman qui est
l'équivalent du prix nobel de
l'environnement et venise venu visiter
ce site aux annuaires coligny
l'année dernière je suis très fier du
supermarché envers c'est parce que je le
trouve redoutable il le redoutable parce
qu'il met véritablement en action les
citoyens consommateurs ils sont plus
efficaces que des années malheureusement
de sensibilisation et d'éducation
il nous rapproche du monde mystérieux
inconnu des déchets en cela c'est une
véritable fabrique de notre réalité avec
simplicité
il ré interroge notre conscience notre
relation avec la consommation
avec le don posez vous la question
pourquoi vous donnez vous donner à une
personne est ce que vous donnez pour
l'objet est ce que vous donnez pour vous
même sur votre ego veut un peu de
reconnaissance
posez vous cette question là le
supermarché inversée et l'air et la
réalité d'un monde en transition vers
une société plus sobre plus durable plus
soutenable
quand nous valorisons nos objets une aux
matériaux nous nous valorisons nous
mêmes nous fabriquons la réalité d'un
futur différent merci
[Applaudissements]